question 179 what is the ruling of rap
in Islam and is their punishment for it
in the religion and I've been asked this
question a number of times the last time
being in North Carolina by a brother who
attends University there so it appears
on Allah knows best that misinformation
is being disseminated and
spread as it relates to the Islamic
stance towards this despicable crime and
probably being utilized by islamophobes
to demonize Islam and the Muslims so I
say in response to this
question seeking the aid of
Allah in Islam rape is regarded as a
Despicable crime a grave sin and a
heinous violation of human dignity and
sanctity its seriousness is underscored
by the severe punishments prescribed to
protect society and uphold Justice
because preservation of personal honor
is a fundamental objective of Islamic
law according to a number of
Scholars and therefore any attack upon
it warrants the strictest punishment the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
said in the authentic
Hadith indeed your blood your wealth and
your honor are
sacred they are sacred to
you they are sacred to you like the
sanctity of this day of yours in the
city of yours in this month of
yours as it relates to rape in an
Islamic Court the rapist is liable to
the had the prescribed punishment for
zena
adultery many scholars further stipulate
that Beyond this punishment the woman
must receive monetary compensation
equivalent to a Dar due to the harm
inflicted upon
her and this aligns with the ruling of
Al IM
when he
said and it is upon him to give her the
dowy equivalent to that of her
peers and the punishment is solely upon
the rapist look at this the punishment
is solely upon the
rapist and there is no punishment on the
victim in any of these cases there's no
punishment of on the woman who has been
raped in any of these cases under
Islamic law there's absolutely no
punishment on the victim she is innocent
and free from any
blame furthermore the senior Scholars
under the leadership
of issued a fwa a verdict a ruling
stating that if rape is committed with
force and violence the perpetrator is
viewed as a public menace
somebody who spreads
corruption and such a criminal is
therefore deserving of the capital
punishment mentioned
inah brothers and sisters in Islam the
honor dignity and security of
individuals are protected are sacred
those who violate these rights face the
gravest consequences ensuring Justice
for victims and deterring others from
transgression this uncompromising stance
as you see in this matter the matter of
rape this heinous crime and Despicable
act preserves the fabric of society and
underscores the value of every
individual's life and
dignity in in contrast to the firm
Islamic stance that we see some
countries have been criticized for their
comparatively lenient approach to sexual
assault where rapists often receive
lighter sentences or early parole and
this leniency can lead to repeated
offenses as we have seen in some studies
they demonstrate that many perpetrators
reoffend we ask Allah
subhana for success and to protect our
brothers and sisters and to grant us all
good in this world